I guess I'm just taking a break we had
this really cool adventure saving earth
and that was pretty happy anyway so I
needed some me time and I came to
Australia and that's when I moved in
with Daryl hello
and here we are you know it's a nice
flat as you can see in uh we get along
well yeah I guess I just wanted to be
around average everyday people Daryl is
an average sort of everyday guy so it
works out well while I'm here I'm trying
to get involved with the lobby's who's
this purple weirdo surprise who actually
knew that was him to give back to the
community
Daryl here is rob lanoue crafter
electronic letter I'm writing to Captain
America and Iron Man there seems to be
something very intense going on between
them and I want to offer my help with my
services dear Tony Stark how's it going
I heard you and Captain America we're
having some relationship problems dear
Steve Rogers do you remember when i
goaded you into killing those prisoners
and you made me swear to never tell the
other Avengers if there's any other
secrets you need kept just let me know
cuz I'm not up to much what are you
doing later I was working what's he
doing he's working keep out Daryl go
through four battles the new mill near
over here taking a nap a little bit of
something I've been roasting in the Sun
for a number of weeks now and it's
almost ready delicious question what are
Infinity stones a lot of information and
ideas and what I like to call little
clues speckled around the place and who
is the man in the purple chair is purple
it's a magic glove doesn't like standing
up fury what does he really know and is
fury his real name or is it actually
pronounced furry little Mjolnir here are
sunglasses in case get the bright and
the rainbow bridge which often it does
if you lift up this little thing what's
your holding me I never wear cut-offs
how do I keep waking up income hops
normal pounds going in cut-offs coming
out you hmm
come on tight we heard from Tony Stark
and Captain America didn't contact you I
haven't received a single phone call uh
one sec hon oh hey t-bone how many times
do we have to go over this no amount of
money is gonna get me to join your
little pissing contest what here talk to
Thor yeah he's sort of been waiting here
from you I haven't right here
oh you can't right now okay am I
disappointed they didn't invite me to
fight with him um no he has to hide it
touch with you I don't I don't have a
phone he doesn't have a phone he send a
raven
I just start my own team team four of
course and it would be me and Darren
just us ruddy
yep
hey youtubers is Charlie so in honor of
the Captain America Civil War blu-ray
coming out they released the thor
ragnarok Comic Con footage this is like
the big documentary that they showed a
comic-con one of the best trailers for
any Marvel movie ever if you guys
haven't seen it the director of thor
ragnarok Taika Waititi did this funny
documentary called what we do in the
shadows with Jemaine Clement this is
basically done in that style so it's
like they're doing what we do in the
shadows with Thor and Hulk so part of
the fun of this is then just winking at
the stuff that happened during civil war
like Thor's like I think there's some
drama going on between Steve and Iron
Man I'm hoping I can help out then how
hurt his feelings get when Iron Man
doesn't call him to be on his team when
he got keeps ducking his calls like what
up you can't can't like he can't pay
Banner enough to be on his team but he
wouldn't want to have anything to do
with Thor so the other side of this
really like the more funny part like
it's funny than waking at the Civil War
plot but I feel like the funnier part is
just the mundane things that he's doing
in his free time like who's this guy
who's this purple guy vision oh wow I
didn't think that you guys would get
that so I don't know whose idea it was
to do a trailer like this if Kevin Feige
came up with the idea if it was taiko
White City but whoever it is please come
forward so we can give you a giant hug
this is hands-down far and away better
than any comic-con trailer that I've
ever seen I would hope that they do this
for all the Marvel films in fact I want
my TV shows to start doing this to like
this is something that you can do that
doesn't require special effects that you
can just shoot with the actors on the
fly and you can improvise a lot of this
too and yet there's been a lot of funny
Thor moments in the past Marvel movies
but if you guys haven't seen
ghostbusters Chris Hemsworth just by
himself is a really funny actor that
usually doesn't come across because he's
playing like some big tough guy but I
feel like Thor Ragnarok is going to show
that off a lot more now Mark Ruffalo
course is fantastic one of my favorite
lines in this like little documentary
trailer is I don't go to sleep in
cut-offs why do I keep waking up in
cut-offs just you know like a wink at
the fact that he hooks out when he's
asleep in Thor messes with him a little
bit the little baby bed for Mjolnir team
Thor high-fives team's door ride-or-die
the trail of evidence that he's building
on the wall here that looks like a
little child did it like it's a little
child's mural like some
eight years old just drew on their wall
Nick Fury is that his real name who is
the purple man does not like to stand up
what are the Infinity stones so what I
really want like a poster of this that I
can hang behind me in my YouTube videos
that would just be hilarious there's a
little child's drawing at the Marvel
Universe that was actually drawn by Thor
in - they're also kind of telling you
what he's been doing this whole time
when Thor Ragnarok picks up at the end
of age of Ultron he leaves the earth to
go back to Asgard to learn about his
vision of the Infinity stones and Thanos
so even though this footage is like the
best non-official Marvel trailer that
they've ever released it also lets you
note like they'll pick up in Thor
Ragnarok with stuff already on the
ground and running and there'll be some
backstory this is kind of that backstory
it's brilliant because it allows them to
skip forward in the story in Thor
Ragnarok they don't have to hijack the
first 20 minutes of the movie because
they'll have already explained all this
stuff that you need to know that's
actually going to be a bigger thing in
Marvel movies like there's so much
backstory that they keep referencing
like infinity war is a good example that
when we get to Avengers infinity war
they'll have to be like a bigger version
of this because there's so much
backstory like remember what happened
with the power gem at the end of Thor
the dark world remember what happened
with the mine gen during age of Ultron
so they're just finding creative ways to
explain stuff that needs to be explained
without hijacking the actual movies but
let me know in the comments would you
rather that they bring footage like this
to comic-con I know everybody wants to
see actual footage from the movies like
mecha traditional trailer but don't you
feel like this is so much more fun and
they can get across the same information
like they'd only been shooting Ragnarok
for about five days when comic-con
happened so they had like a little
concept art reel that they showed off
Hulk and Thor charging each other in the
arena with the gladiator arm on hold
getting ready to punch fire Lord Serdar
Fenris wolf you know some of the other
big things that are going to be
happening in the movie but it was just a
bunch of concept images because all that
requires a ton of CG but this does not
like they were able to show this no
problem it was actually pretty easy for
them to shoot so I feel like they should
do more of this in the future between
the movie just kind of bridge the gap
and just as a fun way to give fans
something but give away time if you guys
didn't know the Captain America Civil
War blu-ray is coming out there's a
bunch of extra stuff on a bunch of
deleted scenes this is going to be on it
the giveaway I'm doing is actually for
the value of the blu-ray just so you
guys can buy it if you want
so rhonu taco congratulations you win
this round of the giveaway please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details and there is a new round that
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so what's going to happen
next is I was originally going to do a
spider-man homecoming video but then
they dropped this
so that spider-man video will post next
well you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to watch the Civil War
bloopers again and you can click here
for all my Ragnarok behind-the-scenes
videos thank you so much for watching
Team Thord high-fives
you